Jean-Philippe Tanguy pour le
rassemblement national oui merci
monsieur le Président Monsieur les
ministres monsieur le corps rapporteur
écoutez à force d'être de décrire des
romans ou d'être vous-même un personnage
well Becker je vous demande monsieur le
ministre si votre perception de la
réalité est des fantasmes n'est pas
gravement entamé je vous vivez dans un
monde qui semble contrôler et vous
donner à l'irrationalité de votre
politique un semblant de rationalité qui
ne trompe personne la réalité c'est que
quand on voit les hypothèses sur
lesquelles votre politique se forme et
les réponses auxquelles vous apportez
vous continuez d'être un capitaine d'un
navire dans une tempête qui n'a plus de
gouvernail qui n'a plus de voile qui ne
sait plus où il va et qui espère que
l'horizon se dégagera d'elle-même mais
l'horizon ne va pas se dégager monsieur
le ministre tout seul c'est aux hommes
politiques et c'est aux dirigeants de
prendre leur responsabilité de prendre
des décisions qui cassent la fatalité
qui permet de reprendre le contrôle de
ce qui se passe le budget que vous
présentez est un budget de soumission
c'est un budget de victimes de la
mondialisation de victimes de
l'inflation de victimes de la guerre et
en plus de victimes qui à allumer un
incendie qu'il ne sait plus qu'il ne
sait plus éteindre vous ne vous attaquez
pas aux pilier qui font l'inflation en
particulier l'affiation énergétique ce
que vous présentez comme un bouclier
tarifaire n'est qu'en fait qu'une
subvention par les contribuables de la
spéculation vous êtes en train de faire
payer par les impôts des Français ou la
dette des Français par le déficit les
marges ahurissantes infondées injustes
spéculative des énergéticiens et vous
présenter le fait que vous récupérez un
surprofit qui n'a pas lieu d'être comme
une action politique mais vous ne faites
rien vous ne faites que récupérer un
argent qui n'a jamais appartenu à ceux
aux vertus vous le récupérez pareil sur
les illusions les injustices vous
prétendez vous cherchez de l'argent mais
il y a déjà eu autant de bénéfices qui
devraient taxer à leur juste reproporion
il faut rétablir cette justice fiscale
les injustices aussi c'est dans les
tabous que vous faisez vous ne faites
toujours rien sur le fioul comme s'il se
passait pas à drame social en France
vous ne faites rien sur le bois alors
que c'est votre gouvernement qui a
incité les gens à chauffer au bois il ne
s'en sortent plus enfin les grands
tabous l'Union européenne 26 milliards
on y touche pas le déficit de la dette
on y touche pas et l'immigration
évidemment on y touche pas c'est sûr
qu'à partir du moment où vous sortez 100
milliards de dépenses publiques de
l'action politique vous subissez voilà
donc maintenant il y a un moment les
Français qui nous aurait dû se demande
quand est-ce que vous allez reprendre le
contrôle de la situation arrêter de
faire payer au contribuable toutes vos
erreurs merci Jean-Philippe Tanguy je
note que vous avez toujours un rapport
compliqué à la vérité
parler de soumission matin midi et soir
je dois dire qu'en matière de soumission
vous en connaissez un rayon soumission
Vladimir Poutine soumission la Russie
soumission à la violence de l'armée
russe refus des sanctions contre la
Russie je le redis en matière de
soumission vous parlez en expert
partant de justice fiscale je rappelle
que le seul État qui s'oppose à la mise
en place d'un impôt minimum à 15% pour
éviter les visions fiscale optimisation
fiscale c'est la Hongrie de Monsieur
Orban que Madame Le Pen soutient matin
midi et soir quant au fioul vous avez
sans doute oublié que vous avez voté 230
millions d'euros de crédit de soutien en
ménage qui se chauffe au fioul je vous
le redis vous avez un rapport compliqué
à la vérité c'est dommage quand on est
membre de la commission des finances
Jean-Philippe Tanguy vous aviez demandé
un rappel au règlement je vais vous
donner ça me permet d'indiquer que en
théorie la séance qu'on peut les faire
pas en commission je vous avais dit oui
donc je vous le passe et si on arrive à
faire en sorte que dans nos échanges on
reste aussi éventuellement en désaccord
sur le fond que courtois sur la forme ça
nous permettra d'éviter les rappels au
règlement je tiens ainsi à ça dans cette
commission merci merci monsieur le
Président je n'ai pas d'autre choix que
de faire un rappel au règlement puisque
monsieur le ministre le maire a non
seulement gravement mis en cause les
élus du rassemblement national mais même
c'est nous a injuriés en autant dire que
nous étions soumis à la violence de
l'armée russe Monsieur le Maire vous a
le droit d'être ivre des propres
mensonges et de la propagande d'État
vous n'avez pas le droit d'oublier qu'en
tant que ministre de la République vous
devez respecter les élus qui fait ici de
quelques parties qu'ils soient et à
partir du moment où vous avez évidemment
évidemment aucune preuve du début des
insultes que vous préférez à notre égard
les tiques républicaines vous impose de
vous taire et de ne pas proférer ce
genre d'accusation qui sont un véritable
poison pour la démocratie et nous avons
fait une résolution nous allons déposer
une résolution pour enfin ces mensonges
d'État cessent en faisant une commission
d'enquête parlementaire qui montrera si
oui ou non il y a des ingérences
étrangères et nous n'avons aucun
problème pour ouvrir nos coeurs et notre
réalité on verra si vous vous ouvrez
votre réalité vos cœurs aux ingérences
qui peut être un flux de manière bien
réelle vos décisions